es ist fast so hart wie diamant und bei
extremer hitze entstanden
ein russisches forschungsteam hat jetzt
ein völlig unbekanntes material gefunden
das es so auf der erde nicht gut was er
bisher über dieses außerirdische
mineralen namens ua kritik wissen dass
er vater jetzt mal geht es im science
fiction herzlich willkommen
der besuch aus dem weltraum wurde
benannt nach dem fundort des meteoriten
das bisher unbekannte material heißt ua
geht und der methode indem es enthalten
war wurde im jahr 2016 in der
sogenannten uhr kit region in sibirien
gefunden und er hat was mit auf der erde
gebracht was es hier so bisher nicht gab
das darin entdeckte mineral kommt nur zu
einem sehr kleinen anteil in den
methoden vor und ist nur unter dem
mikroskop sichtbar tatsächlich sind die
mineral stücke mit fünf mikrometern
kleiner als unsere blutkörperchen die 6
mikrometer großen konkret handelt es
sich um einen treat das würfelförmige
kristalle bildet und aus vanadium
stickstoff und einem kleineren anteil
aus chrom und eisen besteht spannen
dabei ist das element hat ähnlichkeit
mit anderen kosmische mineral
verbindungen die stickstoff beinhalten
der mittel selbst besteht hauptsächlich
aus eisen genauer sagt aus kammern zieht
und das zu 98 prozent dabei handelt es
sich um eine eisen nickellegierungen die
mindestens 90 prozent eisen aufweist
weiterhin konnte das russische
forschungsziel mehr als zwölf weitere
minerale bestimmen die sich zum großteil
eben nur in gestein aus dem kosmos
finden lässt sie entstehen erst bei
deutlich über 1000 grad celsius auf der
erde findet man solch eine
zusammensetzung eben nur im meteoriten
die fachleute folgern daraus dass der ur
petit metroid bei sehr hohen
temperaturen geformt oder mehr als 2000
grad celsius diakité kristalle sind
meist ungestört und lassen somit darauf
schließen dass der stoff sehr früh aus
der eisen nickel schmelze aus
kristallisierte und somit ein
eigenständiges material bild sie zukommt
das von anderen betrieben einer
ähnlichen
umsetzung keine spuren gefunden werden
konnten doch weil sich nur so wenig von
dem außerirdischen mineral in den
meteoriten befindet kann das neue
element nicht in allen einzelheiten
analysiert werden
dazu das forschungsteam
unglücklicherweise ist es uns aufgrund
der sehr kleinen körnung nicht gelungen
alle physikalischen und optischen
eigenschaften von ua kritik zu ermitteln
dazu seien weitere funde mit einem
höheren anteil des elements notwendig
oder eben weitere weiter entwickelte
technologien so wissen wir bislang also
nur einige dinge zur zusammensetzung und
struktur des minerals mit
hundertprozentiger sicherheit das
forschungsteam versucht aber andere
physikalische eigenschaften des elements
aus vergleichen mit vanadium nitrit zu
bekommen so folgern die fachleute dass
das element sehr hart ist es erreicht
auf der entsprechenden härte skala einen
wert von 9 bis 10
damit ist es eines der härtesten
bekannten mineralien überhaupt und
reicht sogar knapp an diamanten der
tatsächlich die zehn knackt das
forschungsteam geht davon aus dass
pakete ausschließlich im weltall
vorkommen kann und zwar in eisen nickel
asto ihnen die bei hohen temperaturen
geschmolzen sind
doch eine ausnahme gibt es
wahrscheinlich und zwar den erdkern auch
er besteht vermutlich aus eisen und
nickel
ob sich ua christoph auch befindet das
werden wir wahrscheinlich nie erfahren
und wenn ihr zu diesem und allen anderen
themen kein video verpassen wollt dann
habe ich am ende des videos noch einen
kleinen trick für euch jetzt aber unser
hochgestecktes ziel keine werbung mehr
auf gigs mehr schon angefangen immer
mehr videos sind werbefrei dank eurer
hilfe tausend dank immer wenn wir
entsprechend viele kanal mich wieder
gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung
vor einem video ab werdet also mitglied
hier unter dem video draufklicken und
ihr bekommt noch exklusive extra videos
live streams und noch ein paar weitere
privilegien für einen kleinen beitrag
und wenn er den link nicht findet wir
haben auch noch mal in der video
beschreibung und jetzt der trick wenn
ihr immer garantiert über aktuelle
videos informiert werden wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp nur da bekommt
ihr das aktuelle video und deutlich vor
allen anderen von mir persönlich auf
euer handy einfach hier draufklicken und
da drunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken außerirdische revolution
bei der suche bis dann